first of all you learn that you are not
the smartest man in the room
i i think you in and this is
this is a very important thing to
remember
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
from the ministry of justice to the
startup ecosystem
meet odin assimian ceo and co-founder of
sealed udi takes a vision and makes it a
reality through sound strategy
development
as a savvy entrepreneur he intuitively
sees the threads of opportunity that
wind through an organization
brings them together into a coherent
whole helps others extend their thinking
and drives material business advantage
he is an experienced chief executive
officer with a demonstrated history of
working in the cloud
cyber security and telecommunications
industries he's skilled in government
m a's public cloud services and sales
and pre-sales
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
doing today
i'm good thank you for having me michael
i i'm really excited to have you
uh you know obviously where this is a
really weird time
to be doing these sorts of interviews
and the skies right now are still
not lit up with explosives but but for
now
things are good to go so i'm excited to
gain inspiration as a young entrepreneur
from your journey
ud um just like i articulated before we
started
i don't even know where to begin whether
it's from your time as chief information
officer of the
israeli ministry of justice your time at
oracle
aws currently your your entrepreneurial
journey with sealed
so many different lessons and and so
what i'd love to do is is
ask you what what have you learned you
know
that you feel in your core from all
these experiences
as as you mature with the industry and
you're seeing
a lot of these different companies
interacting in a really massive
scale with different sectors what do you
learn about yourself and about and about
the world we live in in the tech
ecosystem
well you learn first of all you learn
that you are not the smartest man
in the room i i think you
and and and this is this is a very
important thing to remember
uh and and and why is that because
everywhere you go you learn something
new
and uh it's not only to learn it it's or
it's to remember it
and use it in a later stage and this is
what i'm
this is what i'm bringing with with with
i think my
you know caring on my back uh along the
journey that i've done
i remember reflection from every
meetings that i've done
in the ministry of justice in the prime
minister's office
back in oracle in the amazon and
different startups that i've
i've been encountering along the way and
i'm carrying a small portion of every
meeting
of every interaction and um
and using it in in in my uh
you know future journey so this is what
i have learned i've learned to learn
to listen and i'm trying to take it with
me
along the way i know it's a bit
philosophical we also but this is
something that uh
that yeah i love it i love both a
go going up 30 000 feet in the air and
coming down and we also
uh discovered that that we share a
common person that we both
like very much uh that you worked with
at your time in the in the justice
department and my mom and
and so i'm i i love you know how small
this this ecosystem is in this world is
where uh where i get to find these these
awesome connections
ud you mentioned before to me that you
your customer obsessed and you're always
positioning yourself
you're always positioning yourself to to
think as a customer and think through
the customer
what what does that mean in your eyes
listen i've i've been running and
managed uh
hundreds of millions of dollars of
operations as a customer
i worked in front of different vendors
uh from smes to giant uh
u.s corporates trying to provide me
solutions and everything was uh
as they thought that i need to say i i
encourage encounter different um
ways of sales as as as a as a customer
and uh sometimes
they were inspiring sometimes they were
out of the scope
totally and and i've learned
i've learned to be obsessed by what the
customer wants trying to understand what
the customer rewards
and it goes all the way back from trying
to design
uh your product build your product uh
try to find the product market fit and
and and develop solutions that will fit
uh to what your customer needs and what
your customers need is what
he says he is needing not what you think
he is needing
and and always try to
think as a customer when you design your
ui when you design your functionality
when you design
everything that you want to sell how do
you want to buy it to use it
to consume it and so on um
then in the latest and i and i i i knew
that this is
i knew that this is uh this is this is
how things should be
uh i didn't know how to say it until i
arrived to amazon
and when i worked at amazon i've you
know there are lots of
good things you can say about amazon
there are some bad things that you can
say about
amazon that you can learn a lot from
where you are
one of the good things that i've learned
from amazon is
that you you need to think backward
okay and when you're thinking backward
you
you're putting yourself as a customer
and
trying to think what you can do what
you're going to do with the new
innovation that you're going to provide
to your customers
and they they call it a customer
obsessed so you have to be obsessed by
what your customer needs
and not what what you want to sell to
your customer and this is what i'm
trying to do wherever i'm going since
uh now i have the wording for it but um
you know i have it uh back then in my
dna
doing a you know a look at your journey
it's it's really cool because
you're going from working in a
government setting
highly bureaucratic i'm i'm guessing i
you know i had my fair share of time in
similar settings
and then to corporates like oracle
amazon
and now to an entrepreneur running your
own startup is that
is that by chance that you're sort of
going from a lot of bureaucracy to
you deciding what it looks like because
it looks like really gradual steps
towards you know at the culminating and
in this
startup that you're working on today
well you're right you know i i don't
know if i would like to go back to
to work for the government although that
you know the
the scale of what we've done there is
amazing
and and launching projects uh
you know the anti-money laundering uh
system for the israeli uh
anti-money laundering uh department or
the
the the israeli
computer uh authority is is something
that
that or the the the
the the paperless environment for all
the legislative
uh you know system in israel
everything is paperless in israel this
is one of the
first projects in the world that we've
done this is something that you cannot
do
anywhere else uh in the in this scale
but you have to encounter bureaucracy
you have to work with
the tender laws you have to you know to
and this is what i've tried to cut back
when
in my last role in the israeli
government at the prime minister's
office trying to make
things much more efficient uh
with with you know with some success i
must
i must tell i i look at what the israeli
government is doing now with the um
with the cloud uh with the cloud uh
project that they uh you know
forced the the cloud giants to build
infrastructure here
on the land in israel which i think is
neces is unnecessary you don't need to
have region
in ground in israel but you know the
i'm not going into uh into uh the you
know the
one the reasons that the all the the
giants
com compete on that but uh but but
but but bureaucracy uh provides you
a different narrative of thinking things
are going
uh very slow and
i think when you look at business
private businesses how they don't
uh if they would uh rely on the
government
i think we didn't see this prosperous
ecosystem of startups
in in the high-tech industry here in
israel
the reason i'm saying that is we have
like a parallel universe of of
uh conducting business uh if you look at
what's going on with the government and
what's going on in the business sector
those are parallel universe different
way
of conducting business i do believe that
they are
you know we are in the 21st century i do
believe there are
lots of different uh ways on how to make
everything clear uh legit
and fast and and and swift uh with the
with tender process and but we are not
we're not saying this there and it's
sadly to say
i i think because of that we are
losing lots of talent in the government
wherever you go
not only in israel but the in all the
public sector
all around the globe you see that uh
that lots of talented are not going
there they are
moving to the to the industry
what i was saying is that the the
incentives uh
it seems that the incentives have pretty
much shifted as well in the private
sector
along with the public sector if you know
we're looking at you know
young millennials like myself young
entrepreneurs
why they join certain companies after
they gain the education
that both the public and the private
sectors need it is no longer just about
the compensation and is no longer just
about the equity there's a lot of
different factors that go in whether
it's culture whether it's
meaning vision behind leaders and so i i
think that you know
a lot of people need to think critically
about what what what do incentives look
like especially for
for for for this new generation and that
is a little bit different as
and the public sector has to adapt in
some way because at the end
the talent exactly you know the talent
speaks and now udi
a little bit about sealed ai because
after you
you're getting all these amazing
experiences from
from these different organizations
you're deciding now to
be an entrepreneur and to leave this
company and even before you tell me what
sealed ai does which is very very cool
on its own
tell me a little bit about some of the
leadership aspects that you're bringing
as the ceo after having been
a leader in a lot of these other
organizations what do you bring
okay so first of all
you know we started sealed with uh with
a huge
uh amount of technology and trying to
think what we can do with that
silver was uh three patents very strong
er nvno technology
and it was uh meant to
serve b2c customers you know uh b2c
uh ventures and then when i this is
where
where i first met sealed it was called
by other name
and they came to me and said what can we
do with that
and try to think with us what to do with
this technology this is something
interesting
can we do something else with with with
that
and uh and we sit together
i said i don't know let let's here let's
see what and they said together and we
did again
we're going back to amazon we uh we did
what
they do in amazon it's called working
backward
workshop and we we work backward we said
we if we would have those capabilities
and i said with sealed
uh development team and
how can we sell it to the customer what
we can do we drew we brainstormed for
two days in a in a
room and we came out of the room with
with what still is doing
right now and it's totally completely
different than what it was
uh at the beginning and you know i came
to that
empty-handed without any type of
knowledge
of what shield is doing now i'm not
coming from this business
and but this is where we are and this
this is where the journey take take us
yeah i love it so sealed what what is
sealed
so so silt is actually a rag tech
company
a regulation technology company based on
conversation intelligence
okay so we are what we are trying to do
is
uh we are trying to understand
conversations
that happens to be in fintech companies
uh the the the customers of fintech
companies talking to the
cells representative of those companies
and we are monitoring those interactions
and understanding what's going on and
alerting
on different uh regulation breaches
compliance issues and so on this is what
seal does
okay we started this journey
with a very massive
impressive voice over ip
telephony system which can take
any language understand what's been said
in any language and run on
mobile devices and then we shifted that
to compliance to regulation technology
that actually does
uh conversational intelligence this is
what seal does
and how do you bring this customer
obsession
that you learned throughout your career
to sealed today
so still was a journey okay it was
when you look at conversational
intelligence it's like a mountain it's
the everest okay
there's a huge mountain of conversation
and you said i want to understand what's
going on and then once you understand it
there's different use cases and
different variations that you can take
uh if you look at gong gayo okay gong io
gives you best practices for
salespersons kong io course and others
uh you know trying to improve the way
you sell to
to to increase the conversation the
conversion rates of cells and so on and
this
this is amazing those are amazing
companies
and this is amazing path that they took
along
the way up to the conversational
intelligence mountain
we choose a different path okay this
path is trying to understand the
conversation and alert on suspicious
compliance issues okay or or
or or or you know regulation breaches
and so on
there are different other different if
you look at productivity if you look at
sales engagement if you look at uh
at uh at the you know uh healthcare
conversations between patients and
doctors and you want to
uh to understand what's being said to
make the the process more efficient
to alert on different uh
drug prescriptions that have been given
to a patient
if they are not you know going well with
the with his
record if he has allergies there's tons
of different
um aspects uh that you can do
and and provide data in real time
while the conversation is going the
world is there okay we
can analyze audio in real time and we
can provide
insights in real time and we can also
build you know machine learning and
analytical tools on top of that so the
conversation that we have now
can be flow can have you know floating
ideas around us
trying to understand what i'm saying you
know even fix my broken english
and correct it so you can have it
without grammar
um and spelling mistakes and whatever so
so every or or or provide you with
uh with insights and data and even
contradict what i'm saying
by providing you lots of data uh
about what i'm saying and the buzzwords
and everything that i'm
i'm throwing up in the air so so this is
this is this is actually conversation
intelligent this will be
you know i believe that if you look at
the future i think everything will be
embedded into
into augmented reality and uh
and an extended reality and you'll take
the conversation itself the wording and
so on and
and and make data out of it and make the
data work for you and run
you know automatic processes
i'm sold and i i can already think of
you know the massive amount of use cases
that this is
this is so relevant to from from you
know the day by day
uh to organizational to governmental to
societal
it has a lot of implications all across
the board and uh
and you know within just a few minutes i
i'm starting to
to think through the different
implications that are really really
exciting
and with the huge potential for for
improvement across the board
i can't believe 20 minutes are almost up
but i have a few last questions for you
once you're ready for them let me know
well you know you gave me the heads up i
didn't prepare
along the way so try and uh you know
i'll try to shoot for my hip
i i love that a favorite subject in
middle school or high school
physics okay one of you know why
somebody that inspires you oh why
physics
because i was so lousy at it i really
liked it but i'm i didn't have the
you know the patient to study it but i
really like it
i really liked it i didn't know how to
solve one
one you know one question but it was
very interesting
yeah that may be my favorite answer to
this question
in a lot of episodes so thank you for
that one of your role models
somebody that inspires you well
i think uh president shimon peres was
very inspiring person i
met him a number of times personally and
he was
he was a friend of my grandfather
i didn't met them together but i i
whenever i met him i related to him
because he was reminding me my
grandfather he was so smart he was
studying all the time he was so curious
and i think the curiosity kept him alive
and vivid and so this is uh this is one
of my
role models i love it and
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
myself allah stay young
and run faster
one smile yeah
i i you know i'm getting the gist of it
and i'm getting the
the essence behind it and i'm saying
this go back to being customer obsessed
and
and you know looking at things in in a
fresh perspective and i
and i see that throughout your journey
and it's really really exciting
ud thank you for coming on and sharing
with me your journey i really appreciate
it
i really enjoyed these 20 minutes and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you michael good talking to you
today
[Music]
you